[Music]
Arnold Isaac's recently wrote in The
Huffington Post that anti-muslim
activists in the United States were
operating in a post truth era and
putting out alternative facts long
before those phrases entered the
language for the last decade they have
been spreading provable falsehoods
through their well-organized network of
publications and websites chief among
these alleged falsehoods is the claim
that as Isaac says Muslims in this
country have been engaged in a stealth
or civilizational jihad a long-term
far-reaching conspiracy to infiltrate
the US legal system and other public
institutions and bring America under
Islamic law
Isaac sets out to debunk this claim and
he fails spectacularly Isaac's claims
that the Islamophobes
offer only two pieces of supporting
evidence one for each of those claims
Exhibit A is a document falsely called
the Brotherhood's master plan for the
clandestine effort to establish Muslim
dominance in the United States the
Islamophobia network unfailingly refers
to the memorandum as an official
declaration of Muslim Brotherhood's
strategy Frank Gaffney head of the
center for security policy and perhaps
the country's most prominent Islamophobe
called it the Muslim Brotherhood secret
plan for taking down our country Pamela
Geller and Robert Spencer two other
leading voices in the anti-muslim chorus
have written that the Brotherhood lays
out a plan in the document to do nothing
less than conquer and Islamize the
United States Isaac says none of that is
true the document he says dated May 1991
entitled an explanatory memorandum on
the general strategic goal for the group
in North America is real but there is no
evidence he says that it represents the
views of anyone other than the single
Brotherhood member who wrote it now how
does Isaac's actually know that he
invokes Georgetown University's bridge
initiative and David shipler who wrote
about the memorandum at length in a book
as having debunked it yet bridge and
shipler wrote about the memorandum years
ago Isaac's is rehashing what they said
now because there is a real possibility
that the Muslim Brotherhood could be
declared a terrorist organization a
prospect that deeply alarms the left and
it's Islamic supremacists allies and so
once again the evidence must be
discredited and once again this
discrediting founders on the facts the
first direct challenge to the
authenticity and importance of the
document came from shipler in The New
Yorker in May 2015 in a lengthy attack
on foes of jihad terror ship were wrote
derisively of the documents illusion of
importance and claimed that it was a
mere proposal a plea from an underling
unfortunately for shipler the Justice
Department took this memorandum quite
seriously and as much more than a plea
from an underling federal prosecutors
during the Holy Land Foundation trial
stated that it was written not by a
little-known underling but by a u.s.
Muslim Brotherhood Shura Council member
Mohammed Akram odd loony the Shura
Council is the Muslim Brotherhood's
governing body in the 1992 Muslim
Brotherhood directory Akram is listed as
a member of the Brotherhood's Board of
Directors and executive office he was
also identified as office secretary
which didn't mean a clerk but a leading
officer of the organization
secretary-general would be a more
precise translation of the Arabic term
used in the directory the memorandum
described the federal prosecutors wrote
the Brotherhood's strategic goal as a
kind of grand jihad not in other words
one mens wishful thinking investigative
journalist Patrick Poole also noted that
a federal court agreed in a published
opinion with the Justice Department's
analysis of the document even shipler
himself admitted that Akram's memorandum
was one of the documents that the holy
land foundation defense team had
challenged unsuccessfully meanwhile the
bridge initiative debunking centers upon
the claim that the memorandum was not a
formal plan accepted by the Brotherhood
and it didn't have influence in other
Muslim circles however the center for
security policy has noted that the
memorandum contains proposals for event
which do in fact take place a kromm's
explanatory memorandum fits into a
historical context of what the
Brotherhood had done in the past was
proposing to do and what it in fact can
later be shown to have accomplished as
for bridges claim that Akram's arguments
and phrasing in Arabic are rarely found
on the web and not found in Islamic
doctrine or literature the CSP points
out that a kromm's memorandum was never
intended to be read by the public at
large at all but only by high-level
members of his own organization thus
there is no reason for anyone to be
surprised that Akram's ideas are not
widespread online what's more
counter-terror experts
took Akram's memorandum quite seriously
the former US deputy chief for
counterterrorism at the Department of
Justice Jeff brine Holt remarked for the
first time that was almost direct proof
of what we had long suspected about
their true political goals in the United
States something like the explanatory
memo is a bonanza for the art of
intelligence because it actually is the
target or the subject speaking in their
own words about what they intend Nathan
Garrett a former FBI agent and federal
prosecutor noted the organizations that
were on that list represented a huge
segment of the Islamic voice in North
America at the time
the memorandum not only named names it
candidly revealed just how the
Brotherhood viewed the United States as
a target of conquest
now why would Arnold Isaacs and The
Huffington Post be so avid to discredit
this obviously authentic and important
document could they actually support the
subversion and Islamization of the US
whether they actually do or just useful
idiots if they succeed in making the
American public turn away from the
evidence and the initiative to declare
the Muslim Brotherhood a terrorist
organization is defeated subversion and
Islamization are exactly what Isaac's
and the HuffPo are going to get I'm
Robert Spencer Schulman fellow for the
David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the Center for
security policy
[Music]